Mike and I are extremely pleased to have
a good and longtime friend Josh earned
back back with us today on alternative
views Jack was active in our show from
1978 to 1981 and since leaving Austin in
New York City he's worked as a
journalist writing for various
newspapers and magazines he's worked as
a lecturer and most recently he's been
working in a drug treatment Stewart
Center in New York City today we're
going to talk with jack on the problems
with drugs in society talking about some
of his experiences as a drug counselor
and some of his analyses and
perspectives on the problems of drugs
and society so Jack welcome back to
alternative view is great to have you
here well it's nice to be back I have
been watching the your show alternative
views up in New York City on the CUNY
station it's on four times a week up
there very good and I've been watching
you guys age as times happens well in my
I guess it's the ravages of time and
haagen-dazs
speaking of ravages you know we got this
big war on drugs that's got to be a war
on something or other going on so you
are so to speak as a drug counselor in
New York City you're in the trenches so
can you say something trenchant about
the war on drugs well actually I'm not
really in the trenches I think I'm in
the mass unit I'm more more than a foot
soldier I'm a medic and well I think the
first thing to start out with is I think
we need to 86 this idea of the war on
drugs I think it's part of them that way
of conceiving the problem is part of the
problem rather than the solution as a
military type of thing military you have
enough troops against it then you can
wipe it out what do you what do you want
in a war you look to defeat the enemy
first of all we have to analyze what is
the enemy I think that you know being an
old trained as a political scientist I
remember that George Orwell wrote a
great essay in 1948 I think dug politics
and language in it he cautioned that be
mindful of the language that you use
because it shapes how you think about
your problems and I think reaching if
there's something about the war metaphor
that reveals something about the
American character it says that you know
the for our first instinct is to reach
for the gun and I think what we need is
understanding in this problem I think we
need to be looking at not the tactics of
how to win the war but what are the
underlying assumptions of this war and I
think that we don't get that much of it
in the press I think for the most part
we get just discussions of tactics and
not really what are the basic
assumptions behind this effort it's such
a complex subject you have everything
from the junkie and the street to the
pushers to the big like the cocaine
cartels down in Colombia the CIA
involved in drugs right on up through
the White House administrating some of
this and also the use of the drug war to
try to curtail civil liberties there the
medical aspects that it's so complex
where do you start trying to get a
handle on this drug problem well I think
one of the first things you do is to
understand it from my perspective as
somebody who works in the field we don't
see it as the drug problem we see it as
a drug symptom when someone comes to us
and as a social worker you do the first
time you see them you do a very in-depth
intake where you get their history their
life history you do that because you
implicitly understand that people don't
use drugs accidentally they use it
because it makes sense within the
context of their lives and so I think
what we need to do is look about look
look what we do with addicts what we do
in a 12-step at it when in alcoholics
Anonymous Narcotics Anonymous what you
do is you're asked to take in one of the
steps you're asked to take personal
inventory and to write down your
character defects well we as a society
we need to take that same inventory and
to write down our defects what is it
about our culture of
our economic political and social
institutions which are generating such
widespread drug involvement well Jack
let's begin with that topic in your
experience as a council what is it do
you think the drive the people to drugs
that you deal with well it's it's really
complicated it's extremely complicated
let me first of all say that it's not
really a it's sort of provocative to say
the drug is drugs are a problem but
they're the symptom but there's really
no consensus about what what this it's a
symptom of what right let's take for
instance conservatives conservatives
think it's a symptom too they think it's
a symptom of the Cline of personal
responsibility of morals of basic
permissiveness our new drug czar William
Bennett is one of his favorite targets
is the 1960s as a time of permissiveness
you'll say well uses what happens you
get drugs when you you have a society
says if it feels good do it or do your
own thing and any sense that basically
it's we are the present drug problem can
be traced back to the 60s actually you
know William Bennett is a smart guy he's
got a PhD right here from UT our
philosophy depart right and he's got a
law degree from Harvard but he really
ought to be a better student of history
because the actual roots of at least in
our own country go farther back than the
1960s in fact we can trace it back to
the 1860s the first addicts in the
United States were civil war veterans
many who were racked with battlefield
wounds remember medicine was extremely
crude at the time you get a gunshot
wound that a lop off your arm and your
leg and a lot of these fellas were just
in extreme agony at when the war was
over
well the hypodermic needle had been
invented in 1857 and they found out that
you take a little morphine in the
syringe the in the hypodermic and you
got some relief so the first addicts in
fact were morphine addicts Civil War
veterans but it shouldn't stop there in
fact when we talk about cocaine today in
the cocaine epidemic by the way I really
don't use terms like epidemic I really
think that that in many ways the idea of
drugs
contagious and it also gives the feel
that you know people are somehow tainted
so I usually shy away from that but the
first the first time the drugs of
cocaine appeared on the scene was in
fact in the 1880s in the United States
coca-cola the active ingredient in
coca-cola up from 1886 to 1905 was
cocaine well Freud thought it was going
to be the solution to mankind's problem
absolutely there's no doubt about that
nature was a cocaine addict who for pain
well cocaine was anywhere everywhere Lee
and legal it was in every patent
medicine so you know door-to-door
salesmen would come around in fact there
was a there was a syrup that was given
to two teething infants that had in fact
opium in it at the time and it was a it
was I think it was called mrs. Swanson's
or something soo soothing syrup
of course you put that on the gums of
the of the infant and yes it would
certainly stop crying because it would
be in oblivion and if I found opium you
found cocaine you had marijuana use
remember most people aren't aware of the
United States was the last Western
country Western Europe included to enact
narcotics laws that was in 1914 and we
had the odd ironic situation in 1920s
where alcohol was illegal and marijuana
was legal look now if there was such
widespread availability in use of all
these potent drugs during the apply
wasn't the whole country bladdered out
of its mind and all these and having all
these problems that we have today well
actually if you read if you read the
text of the times you read if you read
books and accounts at the times it was a
really serious problem in fact David
Musto psychiatrist historian at Yale has
documented in a book called the American
disease where he traces that history and
there weren't real serious problems it
was not limited to just poor I mean it
was there was a history of
of black workers being given cocaine by
their bosses in order to get get more
work out of them
you also had very you know even the high
society I don't mean that as a pun in
places like New York City in San
Francisco after a night on the town
would retreat to opium dens in the in
the chinatown sections of New York and
in San Francisco as did the writers and
the Bohemian exactly exactly yeah so so
there were serious problems that were
generating that and at the time when it
was understood was there was a retreat
from it wasn't retreat from drug use as
your what what about now we've had
alcohol use I mean centuries millennia
you go back into the Bible or other old
ancient publications and they talk about
people getting drunk so we've had these
psychoactive drugs whether illegal or
legal ever since mankind has been I
don't think there's no doubt about that
in fact the they've done on they found
in archaeologists have found in in Egypt
papyrus scrolls that talked about the
first breweries in ancient Egypt being
in 3500 BC before that in ancient
Sumeria they used to use opium which the
word they used for opium was joy and
this motivates the yellow city and
mysteries had religious cults they used
drugs as do many traditional societies
all over the world up till this day yes
so it's a prevalent yeah and that's a
sure in any society so to blame it on
the 1960s as William Bennett does it
just absurd it shows total historical
myopia well but Bill Bennett ought to
know better
I'll tell you why you're in Lorna sure
he does he's just a propagandist a
right-wing ideologue like all the other
I think he's got his agenda he's looking
to he's got his own agenda that he's
pushing but he ought to know better
because Brook Bill Bennett and I were
born in the same place and that's
Brooklyn New York
right and Bill Bennett and Bill Bennett
knows that there was a drug problem
growing up in the 1940s and 1950s in
Brooklyn New York and that drugs was
alcohol
I grew up in the Beirut section of
Brooklyn there were four bars on every
block and third Avenue and 5th Avenue
and there were churches on 4th Avenue
and the women went to the churches to
pray that the men would drink and the
men went to the bars and the woman's
answer prayers were never answered so
there was a drug problem then but was
called alcohol and it was legal and it
was socially accepted and the churches
were searches were serving wine to go
with their little wafers the jack during
this is other periods the so called drug
or alcohol problem didn't really surface
into media attention during September of
this year there was something like 260
media stories on drugs alone on network
television in the New York Times
why the sudden focus on the drug problem
what does there signify that suddenly
drugs is a number one problem Bush makes
a speech talking about declaring a war
on drugs Bennett's going all over the
country talking about drugs try now well
I think that there you know I'm not
going to prove the idea that they're
there people don't use drugs and that
there are not destructive consequences
for them using drugs I think that since
since Reagan came into office drugs have
been a convenient whipping post now I
think that there's an ideological agenda
here to push I think that in many ways
drugs serve as a diversion from working
at other social problems I mean as I
said before people don't use drugs
accidentally if you look at their
history the people that come to see me
often are coming from life situations
which are really unbearable I deal with
probably 90% of the clients that I see
in my work are minority women who've
been referred from a child welfare
agency in New York City because they've
been reports or allegations that they're
they use drugs and that unless they
agree to go to treatment or at least
submit to an
you Asian by me or people like me their
children are going to be taken away and
when you do the intake assessment when
you do their personal history I mean
sometimes I look at them and I don't
have any wonder why they use drugs what
are some of the common factors the drive
people into drugs that you've
experienced
well obviously poverty is worth hmm
you're talking about people who you're
talking about women who have by the time
they're 22 23 years old have three or
four kids maybe by three or four
different men who were themselves
children of broken homes and we're more
likelihood they were physically often
sexually abused certainly emotionally a
neglected and abandoned poverty poverty
is a key you just race I would imagine
that always keeps people from getting
jobs and well actually yeah there's no
doubt about it I mean these are not
people with a hell of a lot of
opportunities in front of them when you
find yourself in your mid-20s with kids
and you're living in a welfare hotel you
feel pretty trapped and I guess two by
two by some you know some some sort of
temporary relief drugs can do that I
mean there's no mistaking drugs deliver
in the short term drugs are very
powerful their pain relieving they give
people a sense of mastery to give people
a sense of competence give people a
sense of power they're highly
pleasurable but they have long-term
negative consequences but if you have if
you're only living in the immediate if
life doesn't look well I well down the
road can you blame them check before we
get into some of the long-term negative
consequences of drugs and what you've
experienced in this regard can you talk
a little bit about how drugs are also
symptomatic of an American tendency to
find solutions to problems through
commodities in other words the drugs we
read about on television cocaine
pack heroin etc are similar in some ways
the valium to tranquilizers sleeping
pills
aspirin any number of other drugs that
are used in this society simply to
relieve pain and to give relief that are
legal so this is there a tendency in the
society that advertised in the media and
just the culture in general reinforces
that if you want to solve your problems
you take a drug there's a commodity
solution why don't know to what extent I
could add to that that's was that a
question don't you think that that
that's a main that people don't see
anything wrong with this because it's
part of the culture I would listen I
would say this and no less than one of
the fathers of our country the fellow
who penned the phrase the pursuit of
happiness
is Thomas Jefferson he also penned that
that the art of life is the avoidance of
pain mm-hmm and and in fact I don't
think we should you know when we talk
about where anti-drug and war on drugs I
think first of all we should understand
the drugs have have a beneficial role to
play in society in our lives it's made
our lives
first of all longer we were alive and
healthier all of us would not be alive
today without penicillin and antibiotics
and an aspirin and the various other
even more even Apple or drugs that have
kept us alive and say in emergency
situations so so that's important to
keep in mind a drug is any any substance
which is psychoactive which is can
change mine or mood or body right so but
what happens is I think in a society
that that gets society that seems
distress the society has lots of
problems that don't appear on where
where solutions don't appear on the
horizon it's very tempting to look to
substances that are just a swallow away
from getting some relief but they're
it's more than just this people and the
media and what we've been focusing on
now is the poor people in
ghettos who are trapped in there in
emotional pain and helplessness but
there are articles about the the
wheelers and dealers on Wall Street
using cocaine there are plenty of
alcoholics who make good good living now
and as we've seen that homo sapien has
been doing this of all classes for four
millennia
so what is there that's different
well I wouldn't I wouldn't there's a
fella a researcher and you from UCLA
named Ron Siegel who's just written the
book hole intoxication the search for
artificial paradise where his thesis is
he first looks at the animal kingdom and
then trade and traces it later into into
human beings his thesis is that it's
that the desire for intoxication the
changing of consciousness is in fact
built into the species and and as a drug
counselor that's not a popular position
today but I mean that's all I can say is
that in your point about poverty listen
to the Kennedy kids had drug problems
David Kennedy killed himself from an
overdose of I believe cocaine Robert
Kennedy was when he was on the staff of
Robert Morgenthau and in the
prosecutor's office in in New York was
in fact arrested for possession of
heroin
you have John Belushi you have baseball
stars you have athletes you have movie
stars you have Kitty Dukakis drinking
rubbing alcohol because there was no
booze left in the house obviously it's
not just the function people's intake of
drugs is not just the function of
poverty there are other stresses in life
I mean there are stresses to stay at the
top you talk about Wall Street
I have friends of mine work on Wall
Street nobody gives pays you 150
thousand dollars a year unless you
willing to step over dead bodies in our
culture it's high-stress its its
Fastlane it's very competitive it's a
world where you do never show your
weaknesses to anyone it's a world of
rugged into
brutal and predatory Moodle and
predatory instincts that's that that
takes a toll on the spiritual and
emotional health of a human being and
that's no wonder I mean today they're
using cocaine but historically Wall
Street was always a place where people
got wasted after work on alcohol
now they generally mix the two you know
you take out you take the cocaine during
the day to find the energy the
wherewithal to deal with the fatigue
issues and then after we you get to
wired up and Rea see that you have a few
drinks in order to float that down back
down to earth check let's let's focused
on this question of drug abuse granted
that all societies in history have had
alcohol drugs and other things to
relieve pain to help people cope with
stress and different problems and
granted also that a lot of drugs are
useful to the human being
what then constitutes drug abuse and
then let's get into some of the
destructive effects of drugs as you see
them okay well we as a person who works
in the in the helping profession rather
than the police profession the police
and law enforcement take a view that any
use constitutes a beaut right we don't
la we don't we take the view that we
look at the context of a person's life
and say to work when when a dependency
develops where the use has negative life
consequences then it becomes abuse in
our mind so that means we'll be looking
at a person's emotional health their
physical health their financial health
how they're getting along with their
families going to work their money
that's that's essentially the
distinction between use and abuse in all
societies as you say people have used
drugs but there's a there's a there's a
markedly different effect that cocaine
has on a Bolivian peasant who takes a
coca leaf and begins to chew it first of
all it's spread throughout the whole
body and you end up getting about five
percent of the potency
the drug its longer-acting and it has a
way of one curtails hunger which is of
course important in countries
third-world countries where people are
starving or or malnourished and as a way
to help them work and many of them have
to work brutally long hours but in our
country with the modern technology
available in the processing of the drug
when you snort cocaine you go from five
percent that Bolivian peasants get to 85
percent of purity even better yet if
your idea is to get wasted is is the
either freebasing the cocaine which is
smoking it or crack form when you're
getting 98 percent of the purity crack
within five seconds of your ingestion
goes right through the brain web and
activates the pleasure centers of the
brain and gives you a power-packed 12
minutes where you're on Mount Olympus in
terms of pleasure problem is and around
the thirteenth fourteenth and fifteenth
minute and getting worse you start to
feel withdrawal symptoms that might be
irritability might be the onset of
depression cravings even paranoia and
what do you do well most people they get
another five bucks or eight bucks and
and take another hit and so then they're
on the cycle then they're on the cycle
of dependency and here's where it
becomes destructive for people's lives
extremely so even some scenarios of
lives being destroyed or some of the
processes through which people are
literally destroyed because of drug
dependency well I mean I don't know
where to start Mike Mike my clients are
are people who whose stories just just
our are heartbreaking you know you have
the young woman who came to me who was
19 years old and middle class white
woman who her father she was an only
child and her father her father had
passed away from a heart attack when she
was 14 and her mother died from cancer
lung cancer when she was said
19 she was left the house she sold the
house for $125,000 and heard a boyfriend
in the space of less than a year went
through hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars in cocaine when she came to to
me for help I had to give him five
dollars to take a cab back home want
even more dramatic I was telling you
last night we can let the audience know
we were talking last night and this
story struck you guys was the time that
a man and wife came to came for help and
he was barefoot and she was wearing his
floppy shoes and I said what's the story
here why don't you have shoes why you
wearing his shoes and she said well on
the way over here she sold her her shoes
for $10 so we could both get a hit of
crack now to me that bespeaks the
desperation that that really tells the
story about when the line is crossed
between use and abuse and we have
stories of people people selling their
babies pampers and diapers for money for
drugs that throws other people into
crime which is another I mean I'll give
you another institution I'll give you
another example a woman who were who
lived in a welfare hotel I mean this
really tells you the sort of the engine
ingenuity of some of them drug dealers
welfare help in New York City welfare
you get a check once once a once a month
and you have to go to an office to get
it so during the month what would happen
is if a drug dealer in a welfare hotel
knows that a woman has is getting public
assistance he'll take her card and hold
the card and he will give her drugs on
credit on credit and when they come back
when the time comes they both will go at
the turn of the month they were both go
to the welfare welfare office to get the
check she will then immediately turn
over
the money to him and he of course would
have charged her double because you're
paying double on on her on credit
that's just that a sample I mean we
could go on for hours talking about the
stories the horror stories people's
whole lives then are involved in getting
money for drugs using drugs and then the
aftermath the down dealing with the same
cycle of anxiety depression it's wrong
it's listen it's a full-time job being
an addict full-time job that's where it
destroys your life is completely eggs
become single-minded obsession okay I
mean you're looking at somebody who gets
up in the morning if you're heroin
addict you get up in the morning and
within a very few hours you're starting
to get cold chills sweats diarrhea
vomiting you've got to find some way to
get the dope so the first thing is you
gotta find some way to get the money
right okay if you look at a hook or
crook or whatever you're going to do to
get it then you got to find somebody to
cop the dope from you got hope that it's
good stuff and they're not giving you
some some garbage they've cut it with
then we got to find a clean set of works
because if you don't get a clean set of
works today you can get aids in the
bargain my works you mean a hybrid or my
preserving epidemic syringe a cooker
cotton etc you got to get the whole the
whole the whole works then you got to
find a place to shoot the dope cuz
you're on the street looking for alright
and then you get a couple of hours of
Nirvana and then we begin the cycle all
over again
alright that's a full-time job and
expensive how what is they what does it
cost an attic a day for heroin or a
cracker well let's take heroin there are
people who survive on on $50 a day
heroin there are the people who use $200
a day heroin but crack at five to eight
to ten dollars a pop I know people who
go on what is called in the in them in
the subculture that I work with it's
called a mission a mission yeah they'll
say I guess it's like George Bush said I
it's it's my mission remember you said
that on is or if well they go on a
mission where essentially they they just
leave it all they go to the crack house
and they don't come up for air for two
or three days and they'll go through six
hundred to a thousand dollars in that
two or three days
now yes where do they get the money well
anyway any any any way they can for
women often the bargain is sex they
trade they trade sex for drug in the
bargain though they get more than just a
high from the drug many of the men who
frequent the crack houses in addition to
smoking cocaine
also our intravenous drug users very
popular today is to shoot cocaine and
heroin together it's called speed
balling why is that
well you see that understand something
about the pharmacology of the drug and
its effect on the body
cocaine will is a stimulant a very
powerful stimulant and it will it
excites the part of the brain that's
very much in the pleasure center of the
brain and you will get very very high
problem is how you get the heart of your
fall and what they discovered is by
putting heroin into the hypodermic to
the syringe they've discovered that once
you get way high up in a sort of
time-released way the heroin begins to
kick in right after so you don't suffer
which Ronal effects you sort of
powerchute down to earth in the in the
billows of a nice heroin cushion so that
the speedballing the cocaine and heroin
go go together wonderfully for a lot of
these fellas they use the drugs that way
the women come in thinking that well
these are guys that don't use IV drugs
they end up having sex with them then
they're going back to their partners
many of whom are unaware that they're
using drugs or have gone to the crack
house they transmit it to their sexual
partners they have babies that have AIDS
and the babies won't live to see
kindergarten to what extent is this one
of the main problems in the drug culture
that is AIDS absolutely do you see much
of this is this really problem
tremendous ok tremendous amount at the
gay community should be absolutely
applauded for what they've done they
have really cut it down to virtually
zero increase in the gay community yes
you see people having AIDS but these
were people who were exposed to the
virus
long before the publicity came out that
there
the connection between unsafe sex
practices and any HIV virus amongst the
the intravenous drug using amongst the
drug culture there is almost no talking
to them we have attempted to the New
York City Board of Health send people
they weighed out into the intravenous
drug abusing community attempting to to
get them to use protected sex if they're
going to have sex and it's virtually
impossible after won't remember these
people these people don't have they
don't have a long horizons they don't
think of life in terms of a long horizon
so and they're very resigned and
defeated to the idea that life is going
to be very short for them so to talk to
them about safe sex and about not
getting AIDS and not giving aids to
other people they've been a very
difficult community to reach and that's
why you see such an explosion of AIDS in
the intravenous drug use and community
and essentially that has been the bridge
to the heterosexual community because
it's through the IV drug users and their
partners that it gets into the
heterosexual population they just
fatalistic the fact that I mean they all
should know by now that if they share
needles are liable and get AIDS and yet
they continue to do it is it is
they just anyone like you say this this
short-term outlook and they say oh well
I think if you've been in the community
a while you're already exposed I think
they basically take the view that you
know I've been shooting drugs for five
years or six years or three years or two
years and I've already been exposed it's
so what am I going to worry about the
you know yeah this this you know the
horse has already gone out of the barn
here so they figure they have it anyway
they're going to have it anyway and they
basically I think their their view their
view is I might as well enjoy what
little life I've got left Jack there are
two drugs which cause more deaths than
any of the illegal drugs and those are
the legal drugs of found in cigarettes
and tobacco products and an alcohol can
you give us an idea of the comparison of
those two compared with the illegal
drugs as far as that yeah that's you
know you know that's really interesting
I go out into high school I talk at high
school it's quite a bit and and I asked
them one of my trick questions because I
said one of the most popular drugs in
the world and of course they're used to
hearing about cocaine and marijuana and
PCP and angel dust and LSD and heroin
and like and that's their usually their
answers they're very surprised when I
tell them the three most popular drugs
in the world are alcohol nicotine and
and caffeine they're very surprised
first of all they don't think of those
as drugs after all drugs are bad and
what if they're drugs where we doing
selling them but you're right Frank I
think your question hints at that we
have a blind spot when it comes to
nicotine and alcohol in this culture I'm
also people are also very surprised
considering the attention that's put on
illegal drugs and how devastating and
deadly they are when they find out the
statistics that anywheres anywhere
between 400 and 450 thousand people die
every year from alcohol and nicotine
related disease you know cancer heart
disease emphysema and alike but two
years ago the statistics were totally
less than 6,800 people died totally from
direct effects of only illegal drugs in
the United States combined so that means
that more people die in one week from
alcohol and nicotine related disease
than in one year from all the other
illegal drugs combined so one might ask
why is it that we have this double
standard I think you have to look at not
only the politics we have to look at the
economics here you're looking at a multi
multi-billion dollar industries of
cigarettes and alcohol with great
political influence as well as media
influence media glamorizes the use of
tobacco alcohol etc while it
sensationalizes and villainize --is in
the news programs other drugs so this is
obviously a part of the source of the
doubles thing I'm very glad that this I
mean I tell you as a drug counselor I'm
very glad that we we do villainize and
we do point to figure at nicotine and
alcohol
III just you know I think it's extremely
important they are very dangerous I
think we are as a society
getting away from glamourizing
cigarettes I mean you can see it today
or you go into restaurants there's no
smoking sections going to plane you
can't smoke I applaud these these things
but the fact of the matter is is that we
should understand partly our problem of
focusing in on illegal drugs is that we
forget that in all in one way or another
all of us buy into the drug culture I
think it I say it sometimes when I'm out
and talking to groups you know we have a
society it's basically are an ADD
addicts are us if you if only it's only
by basically sailing out in isolating
illegal drug users that we we don't
understand how much and we have in
common they haven't come with the rest
of us as somebody who drinks four or
five cups a day of coffee how they feel
in the morning if they don't get their
cup of coffee they tell you they're
going up the wall as somebody who's
trying to give up smoking how difficult
it is to give up smoking those people
are addicted Mark Twain's famous line
was when he was asked if you'd ever give
to have you ever tried giving up smoking
and he said yes thousands of times well
the former attorney not Attorney General
a Surgeon General said that that was the
most addictive substance very very
powerful very powerful drug but the can
you continue on my point it isn't just
the problem of addiction is not just
those things which we ingest into our
body a lot of people are now beginning
to see addictions in a much broader
context are beginning to see well we're
not only a society that that is drinking
and drugging ourselves to death but it's
also a society that Gamble's and they're
saying listen we couldn't just go to a a
tonight or NA tonight Argonaut rhotic
synonymous or cocaine anonymous we could
go to gamblers and honors if you
actually if you have people before you
who are a gambler you ask them why they
gamble the real gambler will tell you I
don't gamble for the money i gamble for
the action or as gamblers say the juice
I know because I was
some compulsive gambling I was once a
guy that at 21 years of age I'd come out
of a card game after being with a bunch
of you know fat balding Algar smoking
bad breath guys until 11 o'clock in the
morning on a beautiful spring day
playing cards all night long and you
know what I'd say where's the next game
it had a complete hook it hooks into me
and I did it because I loved the juice I
love that feeling of exhilaration in
power that I used to get in gambling it
was wonderful because I'd always feel a
sense of mastery when I won but I always
had the ability to say I had bad luck
when I lost so it was a kind of
convenient out but I love gambling
gambling so there was very much an
addiction and it was an addiction that
suited my needs for excitement I'm I
guess from my own profile I'm an
excitement junkie you know a lot of
people are excited friends fill the hole
in my life this is what needs to be
looked at what in society drives people
to gambling to addiction to drugs
alcohol or whatever to food the food the
food I mean I'm sports to whatever there
is no data value I was something lacking
in society there's an emptiness and a
hole in society that's terrific because
I say to people sometimes I say to
people listen the next time you go to
the refrigerator late at night I want
you to I want you to take inventory are
you going because you're hungry
or are used are you looking for some
meat because you're bored angry lonely
or tired a lot of people are not looking
to feed a hungry stomach but a hungry
heart a lot of people are bored and
they're angry and they're lonely and
they're tired and they're stressed out
and they're fatigued and they look for
comfort and consolation in the
refrigerator how many of us haven't felt
better I know I I come away sometimes
dealing with these addicts all day long
and I have to walk past the pizza place
actually I found out I don't have to
walk past it now and that's why I'm not
going to the pizza place but it would
call to me like Jack come I'm gonna make
you feel better and you know for a while
it does make me feel better so I was
opting through it you people out for
food people out for gambling hey we're
also a society that
one addiction if people always applaud
and that's workaholism you call somebody
a workhorse and they think you're giving
them a partner they'll think you're
giving them a piece of praise fact of
the matter is people are working
themselves to death people are gambling
people overeating hey what's that phrase
shop till you drop when the going gets
tough tough go shopping how do you think
that's about
it's about your point of sowing we are
trying to fill up reales to start at a
society we've taken distraction to a
higher art now what are we trying to
distract ourselves from I think drugs in
these addictions fulfill legitimate
needs in our society which our society
frustrates I think we have a need for
community which in a very
individualistic a very every man for
himself dog eat dog rat based society is
not fulfilled I think we have a need for
community I think we ever need to have a
sense of belonging many of us don't come
from families where we had a chance to
belong many of us are deeply wounded
from what happened to us in our family
settings that's a whole other story it's
a whole under story about dysfunctional
families I mean I was a I'm a radical I
grew up I went to college I never heard
about a dysfunctional family but I grew
up in a dysfunctional family my father
was an alcoholic what does that mean was
he a stumble down Bowery bum absolutely
not he took care of business in fact
when he drank he was a sort of
happy-go-lucky guy problem is when you
caught him on the wrong end of a drunk
he was about as explosive and
unpredictable as you could ever get and
as children and I can remember like when
he'd come through the door we don't
scatter like mice because you had no
idea what what was going to face you so
I grew up in a very chaotic environment
a very unpredictable violent a very very
explosive environment where there was a
lot of physical abuse there was a lot of
yelling and screaming and arguing in
fact I like to tell people when I get to
talking about this sort of thing it's
not pleasurable but there were two
emotions in my house there was red-hot
anger
and ice-cold attachment coldness hmm in
fact I can remember as children although
if I'm the oldest of five children I can
remember all of us retreating into the
television set to watch eyes Ozzie and
Harriet and Leave It to Beaver in a
Donna Reed show and thinking how come
our family is not like this how come dad
doesn't act like this and how come mom
isn't like this and I thought with again
and his children you're so vulnerable
that you think something's wrong with me
why doesn't dad love me you know the way
you know Ozzie loves David and Ricky and
it was a leave scars now at this point
in my life forty years of age I have no
rancor bitterness towards my dad my dad
himself is the child of two alcoholics
both of my grandparents were alcoholics
he had been physically abused as a child
he only passed on what he no knew we've
always known that alcoholism and drug
abuse run in families
it certainly has taken a devastating
toll on my family
I said I'm the oldest of five children
one of my brothers growing up in that
kind of an environment with all of the
emotional baggage it is of being
essentially a victim of almost wartime
conditions I mean they talk about
battered children they really talk about
the same syndrome as Vietnam veterans
post-traumatic stress disorder it's a it
leaves you a sense of emptiness leaves
you always tense you're always feeling
anxiety there's always feelings of
failure there's extreme feelings of low
self-esteem well to deal with that one
of my brothers first got into marijuana
and later at 17 got him 16 got himself
into heroin he was a heroin addict for
11 years as was his wife and
they lived they lived a horror story of
an existence that they have children
they had two children and her children
were taken away
they were unfit parents they lived they
lived it lived in the streets you know
after a while even families that are
supportive basically have to cut you
loose because they're pulling everybody
down you know when they steal the
furniture for the third time we come
home and find the house empty you know
when when they do everything they can to
feed their habits you eventually have to
cut them loose my brother lived that
life and his wife lived that life for 11
years came home one day and said I don't
want to do it I'm going to get myself in
a method on program method on he went on
methadone for six months was very hard
on his liver he had had hepatitis you
can get hepatitis of course before you
could get AIDS you used to get
appetizers from sharing dirty needles
that now you get some much worse and he
he got in methadone and it was bad on
his liver he started spitting up blood
so he got off in about six months he got
offered because he got out of the
neighborhood many of the neighborhood
influences were very difficult so moved
to South Jersey he and his wife moved to
South Jersey they were raising their
kids they bought a house they got their
kids they got their kids back they
bought a house today we won't have it
they beat the habit my brother was
drug-free for five years he was healthy
6 foot 2 185 pounds a beautiful man he
was talking about early retirement he
had IRAs he made $60,000 as a carpenter
last year of his life because it's the
story I have to tell as he comes home
one day from work and he says I don't
think I haven't been feeling well I've
been feeling dizzy so he went to bed
thinking he'd be better the next morning
he got up and they he didn't they took
him to a hospital they did a scan on his
brain they found that he had five tumors
on his brain they took a specimen of one
of the tumors he had lesions and on the
brain and the specimen showed that he
had AIDS toxoplasmosis which is the
neurological disorder that you sometimes
get when you have AIDS so it finally
showed up after all those years after
five years of being drug free it had
been sitting silently incubate
like a time bomb ticking away in his
system and I watched my beautiful
brother and is painful to me to talk
about it he was six to 185 pounds and in
ten months II wither away 275 pounds and
died what happened to his wife
well um she's still alive
she's still alive she is HIV positive
she's has full-blown symptoms but our
understanding of the disease now Frank
is a lot is a lot better and she's been
being kept alive with AZT nor a number
of other drugs that are keeping her
alive but she's lost a lot of weight and
she's a courageous gal and a good mother
to the kids
well what about your other siblings you
said well there's something it's not
where they say - yeah well I'd say they
were about as adversely affected as you
can get
I had another brother I say had because
the story that this my family album is
in black borders
I had another brother who presented very
differently he presented himself as an
American success story often happens
when you come from dysfunctional and
troubled families you're driven to
succeed right and oh and I in many ways
to convince other people that you worked
something and to deal with your own
feelings of self-worth and a failure
well he was driven to succeed he was
very good he went to an elite Catholic
High School in Staten Island New York
that I went to he went away - he plays
football he went away to Indiana
University play put from football there
he came back he took the family business
that was making a million dollars a year
and made it a three million dollar year
in business your dad your dad's best my
dad's business took it to three million
dollars a year he had a brand new BMW he
had a new house he spent more on clothes
in one month than you and I would spend
in five years I know because I won some
American Express bill for one month
$7,000 just closed I haven't spent that
much my whole life you a good friend now
so he my brother was into what what some
people would call master
cover-up to deal with this this these
feelings inside of low self-worth he
wanted to do his best to convince other
people that he was a success and on the
outside he looked like an extreme
success but on the inside he was a who
was that scared lonely angry depressed
helpless ten-year-old grown up worried
about whether his father was going to
beat him he never had dealt with that
emotional baggage he never had gotten to
the bottom of that stuff and he used to
he used to like to take the first of all
you shouldn't like to do exciting things
he and I had that shared that
characteristic we were excitement
junkies right he made me look like a
[ __ ] I mean I gambled and I did a few
things but he really was we're talking
major league he would skydive you like
to jump out airplanes
he'd ride motorcycles 8090 miles an hour
he gambled and I mean gamble big time I
once watched him remember now it's a
three million dollar business so you can
afford to do this at least a while he
once spent $50,000 on the Superbowl and
I was with him in the room when he was
he bet he made that and I watched the
game with him he lost the bet and he
never changed the expression on his face
my brother believed and always
maintaining a cool exterior putting up
an I'm okay
front but you know the only way you can
do that was a little help from our
friends in this case used to take
valiums like six eight ten a day god
he's taking my guests like lifesavers I
guess for him they were lifesavers he
thought at the time and that helped to
like mellow him out because he was
obviously under a lot of tension and on
weekends he would drink maybe a quart
and a half of Stolichnaya Vodka would be
about his night's consumption and one
night he was drinking with his friends
and he collapsed at the bar they said
well he's drunk let him sleep it off in
the back seat of the car they put him in
the back seat of a car and left him
there alone to sleep it off sober up
they unfortunately left him with his
head back
and the body is a magnificent engine you
know it's a magnificent tool it knows
what it has a poison it wants to get rid
of it with his head back like this see
obviously when he was unconscious he
threw up and it had no place to go and
he literally drowned in his own vomit he
asphyxiated choked to death so in the
space of six months I lost two younger
brothers and I buried them both very sad
but this shows that drug abuse is not
just focused on the poverty-stricken and
the people in in dire consequences the
emotional emotional emotional neglect is
is an equal opportunity destroyer here I
mean you'll find people in you'll find
people and the highest echelon of
government and politics in the economy
often often abandon or neglect their
children after all there are fairly
driven people there are people who work
long 60 70 80 hour weeks as I talked
about before workaholism sounds fine
except you're neglecting somebody you're
neglecting your spouse you're neglecting
your children in many ways you're
neglecting yourself if we are to grow as
many sighted beings we have to do more
than just be single mindedly obsessed
with work or any other addiction which
happens in the addictive process as I
said at the beginning of the program I'm
a battlefield medic and as a battlefield
medic I have to help people with the
tools that are in front of me who come
into my office bleeding and so I have to
help them and try to get them into
treatment try to get them into therapy
try to try to help their children get
into daycare I do what I can but I
always know that basically I'm fighting
a losing battle I just don't have enough
resources at my disposal I also know
that I'm also helping people where the
damage is for the most part already done
to me we I have another role and it's a
rule that most people in a drug
treatment world in fact most social
workers are reticent to play and that's
the role as a social and political
activist because we have to be thinking
about how do we how do we
social arrangements so that we don't
have people using these kinds of drugs
to search of this destructive effect on
their lives and to me the drug issue has
radical implications for the rest of the
society from top to bottom you're
talking about poverty you're talking
about a redistribution of income if
you're talking about loneliness you're
talking about creating institutions
where people can feel a sense of
belonging remember every one out of
every five Americans in the United
States move every year we really are a
rootless unconnected people it's really
a continuation of the great migrations
from Europe where we came left our
families and left our communities came
to America and bought into a go west
young man rootlessness I think that's
played a tremendous cost I think we are
you know as David Riesman wrote in 1960
a lonely crowd or as Phillips later
wrote in the 1970s the pursuit of
loneliness I think we're all lonely
people I think we often find solace we
also in in drugs and other acted Ixion's
their stories make me think that there's
a lot more involved in solving a drug
problem then just say no as Nancy Reagan
would have it or just lock them up and
throw them in jail or or set them to
bootcamp like they're talking about yeah
shock incarceration camps locking people
up actually lock them up fevers is
really sweeping the country right now
they're talking about locking up drug
users not just dealers but drug users
even the casual use yeah and in fact I
mean we already have most people
probably not aware of it we already have
more people in highest percentage of
people of our population in lockup than
in any other country in the world other
than South Africa and there are some
southern states I think three or four
southern states I have a higher per
capita lockup rate than South Africa
yeah I'm not surprised so we already our
jails are already full and we know in
places like New York is spending $50,000
to keep a person in jail and yet we will
not spend we will not spend the money
necessary to have good day care systems
good family therapy you talk about
therapy Doug I'll talk to you about just
drug treatment I get people every day
who come to me and say I'm ready to give
it up I had enough
help me and you know in this country we
have drug treatment but it's a class
system there are over 5,000 treatment
centers in the United States that are
private treatment centers to spend that
cost anywhere from five hundred to a
thousand dollars a day now you've got to
be well heeled or you better have a
major medical wraparound insurance to be
able to afford those treatment centers
that excludes
people on Medicaid or worse the 37
million Americans who do not have when
were working Americans who cannot afford
how to have private health insurance I'm
not eligible for Medicaid they're locked
out of our treatment centers I'm on
you're locked out I'm not well
fortunately you don't have a drug
problem at least at least that you're
owning up to friend that does so so
really I get people all the time who
want help and I have to tell them if
they have Medicaid well I'm gonna have
to put you on a waiting list for two to
three months to get you into into a
long-term resident is your life or
lesson somebody's using drugs they're
they're ready they're right they're
coming in you put them back on the
street if they're first of all using
needles you've got a chance they're
going to share a needle with somebody
they're going to give it to their spouse
they're going to give it to a baby the
ripple effect is tremendous we need to
be giving people treatment on demand in
the end it will even be a cost saver but
the problem in our country is is that
why would we give poor people or addicts
to help when we're not willing to give
the poor help
I mean Reagan was always talking about
giving the deserving poor government
spending well everybody in our society
does not see addicts as deserving them
as deserving poor the most people think
of addiction and drug use as a
self-inflicted wound they have only
themselves to believe I mean I have a
close relative an in-law who tells me
she is she herself is that the child of
an alcoholic her father ran away from a
large family when she was a small child
but she'll tell me she said you know
jack I just don't buy your argument
about these addicts you know you just
always crying a blue streak about these
at
I got no sympathy for them everybody in
life has crosses to bear you don't have
to use drugs and then I think that's the
position most people believe that if if
you want to give up drugs it's just a
matter of true grit it's just a matter
of you know pulling up those emotional
bootstraps and and get into it and I
think it's a lot I think it's a lot more
deeper than that and we need to be
providing help and services and we as a
country are particularly hard-hearted
when it comes to drugs I'll give you an
example we're now spending we're about
to spend 8.8 billion dollars in the Ruhr
on drugs 70% of that is for law
enforcement only 30% of it is prevention
and treatment and even that a lot of it
will go to bureaucracies or to programs
and are ineffective and not down to the
streets to really help the people that I
offer I work in a drug treatment agency
and I can tell you drug treatment is
important but I'll also tell you that
but focusing on treatment is in fact of
closing the barn door after the horse is
gone we need to be thinking about
effective prevention and effective
prevention is to be looking at what is
the dynamics in the society which is
producing people that so much distress
that people feel the need to use drugs
in the first place one of the things I
did not talk about is that when we talk
about drugs we don't we're not aware of
that a lot of people who use drugs on
one way mentally ill a psychiatrist and
Yale did a survey a few years ago 750
addicts in that 750 addicts they found
that 85% of them were either
schizophrenic borderline schizophrenics
manic-depressive or discovered heavy
depressive disorders they were or had
panic disorders or anxiety disorders so
many ways they're taking up substances
where as an attempt to self-medicate
their symptoms because we don't really
have a way for these people to deal with
their problems we don't have therapy
therapy is a really a rich man's sport
in this country you go out and you try
to get a therapist outside of the
University of Texas where you might get
one at the Student Union the hospital
there and you're going to go you're not
going to be able afford it it's 50 60 80
90
dollars a throw and to group therapy you
can't just go once a week you got it up
to three times a week who can afford
that so it's a class bound treatment
center we have and we're also not
looking at the root causes of the
addiction in the first place let things
from what you're saying that there are
basically three reasons we because the
people take drugs one is for excitement
like you say in others for escape and
the third is to lessen emotional pain
you flip those upside down and say this
spotlights societal the total societal
disorder where why do people need
excitement or most of the everybody's
lives boring is their work life boring
is their family life boring and what are
they escaping from why do they need
escape and then the pain what causes the
pain that people are trying to escape
well Frank you will radical you and
that's exactly the we talked about
before is that in fact drugs in some
measure meet legitimate needs that
people have you know we talked about
this you know you listen to people like
Bill Bennett say well this is a
hedonistic Society
this is a pleasure oriented society this
is a do your own thing society frankly
this is a society which in fact has its
nose to the grindstone
we now have families where there has to
be two paychecks everybody is out
working everybody is goal oriented it's
you know like the commercial says where
it absolutely positively has to be there
overnight this is a production oriented
society very work work work I mean where
we get pleasure actually we get prize
you in the form of commodities
commodities in the form of food and the
forms of things that you are part of our
passive spectator culture and why we
passive most of us come home deadbeat
are asked dragon from a day's work and
about the only energy we have left is to
put ourselves into the easy-chair put
our feet up on the Hasek get the remote
control and sit in front of the boot -
glued and take that in that's pleasure I
don't think that's pleasure I know me
with bare wrist apparel with
food with some other means to distract
ourselves we're not a society that it's
all encourages pleasure I think we're in
fact the society that still has a good
deal with a Puritan ethic or in my sense
that I'm raising Affleck and it was
always a lot of guilt about feeling good
is being captive not really not lobsters
not to feel good
Jack it sounds to me like we're talking
about perestroika in the USA that we
need a lot of social restructuring and
social change in our society we need a
new set of values in this set of social
institutions social relations that it's
really this competitive stress society
the social Darwinism that's the survival
of the fittest where if you don't make
it there's really no institutions no
safety net no help to take care of you
it's this individualism gone berserk and
amok in our society that's really at the
bottom of this drug problem and if we
don't start changing our attitude
towards values towards work towards
everything as well as our institutions
we're not going to really be able to
deal with this drug problem begin
dealing with the drug problem we need to
talk about new drug treatment programs
we need to have programs out there that
will help addicts get off the street
that will help people deal with drug
problems that to me it sounds like this
also involves psychiatric treatment
counseling as well as just simply
programs like methadone or whatever
education to get people off of drugs
well clearly if you're if you see drugs
is symptomatic then you look what the
problem is and for me the problem is one
it's very easy to get somebody off of
drugs you just put them in a five day
detox or a ten day detox and their body
is now cleaning the drug that's really a
medical treat that's only a medical
treatment and in fact is only dealing at
a symptomatic level when you put them
back in an environment in an environment
where they don't have opportunity or an
environment where they have lots of
stress or an environment with this not
has be have not been able to address a
lot of the underlying emotional
difficulties they have then they're
going to relapse they're going to go
back and so you have to begin thinking
about this issue in a much more holistic
kind of way and much more totalistic
kind of way then you find policymakers
and
Washington with very easy slogan
earrings about the war on drugs you're
going to need to rebuild the cities it
seems to me that the drug cultures are
precisely that it's whole urban ghettos
whole subcultures where there's nothing
but drug use everywhere you look until
you eliminate these drug subcultures
you're going to have literally millions
of people this is the problem or this is
the problem of the part of the
underclass you see we it's it's that
phrase that's developed in the last 10
10 years it used to be from a class
perspective you had you know you had the
ruling class and then you had the
working class and then the American
sociology didn't like the concept of a
ruling class so they developed a there's
well there's there's an elites and then
there's the middle class and then that's
basically all of us a middle class the
fact is we now have a group of people
who are locked in going nowhere millions
millions of people are going nowhere or
in better and really have their life
prospects are very dim and and as a and
as a political system we've given up on
these people I mean the Conservatives
never never really had much hope for
them Edward Banfield a conservative
urban the urban astrologist said years
ago that we should think of the city as
a as a sandbox basically let's write the
cities off let's understand that they're
basically decadent and we have nothing
we can do for these people they're
hopelessly pathologically degenerate
anyway yes he said to kind of cordon off
the cities to keep the people in and
then pour toys like a sandbox toys ie
drugs and things like this into the
cities keep the people spaced out or
occupied and don't let him out that way
you they wouldn't have in fact the rest
of the site in you wouldn't have to do
anything more about them this was and it
it looks like this is kind of what is
happy that his Frank is it's not just
the Conservatives beginning around the
mid-1970s with with Jimmy Carter when he
began talking about a government of
limits a government where we'd have to
lower our expectations he began saying
things like you cannot expect government
to solve our problems they be can a sort
of neo
ISM a sort of fiscal conservative news
on the part of of liberals that said
listen we'd love to solve all the
problems in the world but we can't throw
money at every problem and so even
liberals there's no consensus today as
at least we gave lip service to during
the Johnson administration of the Great
Society to addressing these problems
we've basically written these people off
and that we actually written them off at
a time when they cannot help themselves
because one of the issues that no one
addresses is a lot of these this
underclass of people have been rendered
technologically obsolete their labor is
now redundant the kind of work that my
Irish grandfather did when he came from
Europe in the turn of the century was to
go down to the docks and on the west
side of New York and to do what they
used to call donkey labor and yellows
had the Irish to do donkey labor and he
on the street the sweater the sweat of
his brow and his Ben and his back built
himself some kind of a life today that
job doesn't exist for people it's been
replaced those kind of manufacturing and
hard hard labor jobs and replaced by
machinery or had been sent abroad to
cheap labor markets you now have a core
of twenty to twenty-five percent of the
population who literally had no
meaningful role paying work for the only
thing they have only prospects they have
in front of them is flipping burgers at
Wendy's which you can't you can't live
on those salaries you can't move on
those salaries and then one of the
reasons why we're talking about drugs
and why people use drugs because there's
a political economy of drugs today in
New York City there are sections of New
York City that are coming back to life
because why because the drug money
that's infusing a renaissance parts of
East New York and Queens where the
Jamaicans and the rest of them the rest
of the drug gangs are pouring that money
back into the community actually Nixon
and the Republicans finally got black
capitalism but now it's in the form of
the drug economy on the other hand
there's other halls
parts of the city that are just
destroyed yes where the crime the crack
houses it makes it impossible as a
living habitat
impossible to escape that drug culture
unless you literally leave it in and how
can you leave it now who has the who has
the dollars to leave it I know a lot of
blacks a lot of the blacks that I treat
as a drug counselor are making the
decision to leave and go back south
that's about the only thing but some of
them have some of them have really was
down to the core areas reversal of the
earlier patterns exactly they came North
for opportunity and now they go back for
opportunity to live because New York
City and the other urban ghettos just
are really uninhabitable at this point
we've been talking about a lot of things
we don't talk about even the crime what
it's like to live in these war zones
where people are getting people are
getting innocent people are getting
wiped out in these gang wars these turf
wars that are happening in the city
teenage death rates are just incredible
I've read several articles in The Times
about this jack one thing we haven't
talked about here is the issue of drugs
and social control
it seems that obviously that once a
certain labor force is obsolete
technologically the society doesn't
really care about them so drugs become a
method of social control to keep the
underclass down to keep pacified a
potentially wristed force in the 1960s
it was precisely in the urban ghettos he
had blacks Porto Ricans Chicanos people
of all different races and origins we're
a radical political force you don't see
this anymore
the drug culture is right has destroyed
the radical political subculture that
makes one think that they may be people
different groups in this society may be
using drugs as instruments of social
control well um you're not the first to
bring that up in fact Malcolm X Black
Muslim leader I saw I saw a tape just
recently of him saying that 1964 just
before he was assassinated in 65 where
he was saying that you know we don't
know the planes it's Y T that's bringing
this in it's a way for us to be chilled
out it's a way for us to be pacified
it's a way for our people to be
narcotized
I don't know if there's any conscious
cabal conspiratorial Klink at
top that is sort of crafty enough to
divine this pretty malevolent technique
of social control but it's certainly
whether or not it's it's by design it
certainly works out that way and a lot
of people I've read and talked to people
who say that during the urban riots of
the 60s and 70s that suddenly there was
an enormous infusion of drugs from the
outside to cool him off though that had
to be something that was planned and
controlled know what I think it is Frank
I don't I don't see it is that I think
that there's so much money at stake when
it comes to drugs that I mean just think
back there Serpico the example of
Serpico the cop in New York tried to be
an honest cop right there's so much drug
money floating around at the end of the
60s and the 70s is that basically
everybody can get bought off everybody
can get a piece of the action so it may
look in fact that that everyone is
approving of it and that at the top is
is basically calling the shots the
people at the top calling the shots but
it really is there's so much money that
almost nobody is immune to being being
bought off and bribed and so it looks
like well the whole community is getting
infested who's there to do the job who's
there to stop it from coming in the
police can be bought these kind of
dollars they're talking about are a lot
of money but Jack the facts of the
matter are that one it's been tolerated
for several decades heavy drug use in
the ghettos and other parts of the
United States have been tolerated
despite the war on drugs the Nixon
Reagan Bush and other right-wingers are
declared they really haven't done
anything okay
they have what you like them to do well
let's talk about this now what would you
have liked them to do would you like
them to start locking people up Nixon
done well there's the point is they
haven't done the things that we're
talking about together the origin of the
drug problem right that our sorry ghetto
life outside I have a different ideology
they have different stakes they're
different they have a different agenda
they have privilege to protect they have
their power to protect theirs all
ideologies built into America that if
you know if you can make it you can make
it on your own even if you're going come
up in the lowest of circumstances
through hard work and ambition you can
rise up by your own bootstraps I mean
this is not a culture that sort of looks
out
a week this is not a culture that you
know sheds too many tears about the poor
I mean I'm not surprised I'm not
surprised I'm not surprised that they're
not looking into arrangements social
arrangements which they see as part of
them of nature they don't think that
they don't think that this is class
oppression they think this is life
yeah there's in life there's winners and
there's losers we're sorry but some
people have to lose and I think it's
important to see that really the war on
drugs is declared by bush and all of the
right-wing solutions to the drug
problems or has simply soot sudo
solutions that really can't work and
don't worry let's take the project of
getting drugs at the source we hear a
lot about the Colombia cocaine cartel we
talked about using US troops to go down
to Colombia in South America and destroy
drugs at the source why do you think
this is a pseudo solution to it really
sort of a smokescreen over the whole did
you leave my mind you knew it was a
pseudo solution how do you know that I
don't think it's a terrific idea well
because we talked about this before well
actually I don't think it's much of the
solution I think in fact it's there's a
tendency in a part of American culture
to always look for outside agitators to
blame always look for to externalize the
problem think of some some bad apples in
the battle in other words American
system is basically a good battle we've
got a few bad apples and if we can get
rid of the bad apples we've got a
basically good institutional
arrangements here so it's easy to blame
you know the drug cartel in general
Noriega and the Contras and cocaine
production just as we blame the Turks
Nixon blame the Turks in Turkey for the
heroin production or the Cambodians and
the laotians and the Thais for the
Golden Triangle production back in the
60s and 70s frankly I think really it's
diversionary because five years from now
maybe even two years from now we will
not be talking about cocaine cocaine
will be passe like good ol American
know-how and technology we are now
replacing natural products with
synthetic products the markets of the
drugs of the future are going to be
synthetic man-made made in clandestine
secret laboratories by highschool
chemists are going to be able to make
money I see it now as drugs like ice and
ecstasy and crank these are all
synthetic drugs much more powerful and
in many ways much more deadly than the
natural products so and again my
argument is why be focusing on Noriega
and the Contras and the drug cartels the
reality is is what is it about American
culture that leaves us so ripe to want
to use drugs I think there's a very
important factor here and that is that
you were talking about Reagan and Bush
and the right-wingers well even Jimmy
Carter this is very important for them
to keep this drug thing going as the big
study group out in California a few
years ago with the police from all over
the country they said hey we don't want
to eliminate crime because then we'd be
out of a job so we got to keep enough of
this going to keep her just like the
Vice squads they don't want to eliminate
Vice in town they wouldn't have anything
to do they'd be out of a job so you got
to keep it going but the people the
Reagan's and the bushes of the world
they want to use this so-called war on
drugs they don't want to stop it right a
bush was in charge of interdiction of
drugs spent billions of dollars during
the Reagan administration and drug
importation is only increased but you
know what you see they're using the drug
war on drugs to curtail civil liberties
of ordinary people or maybe just casual
users they also are using it there's a
method of mucking around in the third
world I noticed that the President of
Colombia when the Americans sent
different types of military armaments
down there to fight against the
Colombian drug cartels he said hey wait
a minute this isn't the type of
equipment we need to fight the drug
cartels but it's perfect if you want to
use it against the the left-wing
insurgent guerrillas and the same thing
I noticed in Peru
Bolivia when the Americans go down their
advisors they're down there under the
supposedly to fight drugs what are they
doing they're not fighting the drug
lords and all they're after the
left-wing guerrillas who are trying to
overthrow the government who won't say
no what's the feel they're allow of
agendas and excuses that they've got to
keep this drug war going that's the
thing I like about alternative use never
asked leading questions on the show
I have another leading question for you
a lot of the liberals and libertarians
in response to this right-wing war on
drugs the Lacey is repressive of our
civil liberties and as extending an
intervention as foreign policy they say
hey let's just legalize it we'll get rid
of organized crime and the
criminalization of drugs we can solve
the prison problem there's tons of
people in prison that cost as you said
earlier fifty thousand dollars a day for
the state to take care of why don't we
just decriminalize drugs if some people
want to destroy themselves okay we can
use some of the money from the profits
from drugs for rehabilitation programs
for other people that want to get off of
drugs what's wrong with this libertarian
legalization are they they also say that
the price will go down on drugs and
therefore that the the addicts the
people who use them won't have to go on
Mother's Day beat up on the the ladies
and little ladies who are getting their
welfare checks or there were Social
Security checks and they won't have to
prostitute themselves in order to get
money because the price will be low so
all the problems the drugs will be
solved by legalization right now I think
what you'll solve with legalization and
on the face of it it's a fairly
attractive in it's a very tightly
reasoned article thesis I think what
you'll do is you'll probably have a
decrease in property crimes which of
course if you have property is always
very people interested in doing if you
have property and and Milton Friedman
and William F Buckley and a number of
conservatives that put this forward as a
means to deal with the drug problem
they're not talking about the drug
problem they're really talking about the
crime problem well that's not property I
mean people get mugged and
streets well yes well that's the win I
said frogfish yeah well I think I think
that's I think that's the that's the
cover I think that's the cover story I
really think that these from a practical
standpoint legalization is a complete
mess let me just let me just pose it to
you we have laws now in this country in
every state that says if you're a
bartender you cannot serve an EPA tour
an intoxicated person in fact in places
like New York you have liquor law
reliability which says if you if you
sell you if you serve an intoxicated
person that last drink and that person
goes out and has an accident you are
responsible for the damages you can be
sued now I would ask you if you were if
we would have states supported drug
clinics actually state supported crack
houses and somebody came in and wanted
to get high at what point would you tell
them that they had enough listen fella
you've had enough you can't have any
more do you know what it's like to tell
somebody who's who's been using cocaine
or crack you've had enough and you're
not going to have any more firstly
you're going to have to have cops right
in there because the restraining this
person when he goes nuts and says I want
more you're not going to stop me but
let's say that he has and you'll give
him an hour's worth of drugs or two
hours worth of drugs but three hours
worth of drugs how about the fact that
we know that when one single use of
cocaine can cause a heart attack as it
did for Len Bias the basketball star was
there who was drafted by the Boston
Celtics he died right out run single use
of cocaine here's a healthy man
especially now we're learning about
cocaine and blood how it interrupts
blood flow to the heart are you going to
give people enough drugs to let them
kill themselves if they kill themselves
is the state going to be responsible
who's going to be held responsible when
they do that are you going to allow
pregnant women to get drugs in these
state-supported crack houses or drug
dens because we know what the effects on
the fetus of the drugs we know that a
single use of of cocaine can stroke a
fetus and can break the placenta open a
can
lead to death in the womb we could allow
pregnant women to have it at what age
are we going to stop people from going
in is it going to be 14 16 18 21 for
those people who you don't allow into
your state-supported crack houses or
legalized drug dens where can they go
they'll go to a black market the black
market will still exist for the youth
for pregnant women for those people you
don't allow to have any more than
they're there they're there narration I
think it's a complete folly and I think
of we as political people I'm not just a
drug council I'm still wear a political
hat we should understand that this is
basically has an agenda it's part of the
final solution to the underclass the
legalization the legalization you eat
them under keep them under a chemical
yoke for the rest of their natural lives
and those lives will be much shorter and
by the way when you talk about crime
will be go down having grown up as a
child of an alcoholic I know that the
kind of devastation that that a person
under the influence can do to children
under the loved ones around them what do
you think these people who are going
getting high at crack at that
state-supported crack houses what are
they going to do when they go home to
their families and loved ones
can you imagine what what life is going
to be like driving in cars it's bad
enough to 50,000 people get killed on
the highways from from drugs
what is life going to be like when you
know that the guiding guy who's driving
alongside of you in the next Lane has
just come out of a crack house I think
life will be much more explosive much
more dangerous much worse I don't want
to see people have are freer much more
accessible hassle free drugs I think we
just need to be dealing with root causes
and legalization doesn't deal with root
causes legalization just deals with the
symptom they want drugs will give them
more drugs just leave us alone if you
want to kill yourself go right ahead
it's none of our business
so that criminalization hasn't worked
either as a waste
Plus as we talked about that the very
first of the program a long time ago
homo sapien and other animals have used
psychoactive substances ever since
they've been in existence so you have a
contradiction here do you not about how
are you going to prohibit on one hand
criminalize something which seems to be
inherent in the human species the desire
for some type of psychoactive experience
the desire I think that human beings
have is a desire for for pleasure a
desire for for belonging a desire for
meaning and purpose in their life a
desire to be connected to other human
beings in a meaningful way a desire to
maybe have an out of mind experience yes
to experience pleasure and excitement
sure these folks are tense but we have
other means for people to reduce tension
there's men this meditation as all kinds
of this there's massage there's
relaxation devices we can be teaching
people we can be building into the
culture means other than chemical to
help people deal with their emotional
problems I don't think that yes
criminalization hasn't worked that's one
of the strongest pieces of the late
those who argue for legalization is the
criminalization doesn't work I'm
absolutely in agreement it doesn't work
but legalization would only make things
worse Jack what about making a
distinction between those drugs that are
known to be destructive and harmful let
us say cocaine the latest surveys on
cocaine do indicate they can bring heart
attacks about crack we know is addictive
and destructive which is a cocaine
derivative can we isolate as a society
what drugs are definitely harmful and
destructive let us say cocaine heroin
crack etc alcohol alcohol alcohol is a
seriously destructive well I guess I
mean listen what you're left with is one
of the problems that we Malaysia one of
the problems is with legalization is
that you could you literally could might
be able to technically legalize heroin
because a heroin addict could might get
off two or three times a day
but a cocaine and it gets all six times
an hour but is this a solution legalized
marijuana legalized even heroin some of
these other new chemicals these
synthetics that maybe aren't destructive
in the same way that crack cocaine etc
are so you provide some pleasurable
anxiety reducing experiences for people
yes we do prescribe drugs in our society
I mean doctors prescribe drugs
I mean pharmaceutical houses are the
biggest pushers of drugs in the United
States I mean we have a commercial that
says for new print I think it says when
you haven't got time for the pain
there's marijuana any say more
destructive than alcohol tobacco or
valium or some of the chemical drugs are
sold over the counter for one example
for one example it's clear that the
people that I know who with who use
marijuana habitually that they
definitely have Merril memory loss they
definitely have short-term memory loss
and I just watch what you say now you're
up to your old tricks
so as memory loss they really think they
believe there's issues of sterility they
think there may be changed and they may
they they they hypothesize that there
may be change in the genetic structure
from marijuana I think the jury is still
out them about using marijuana if I had
to rank order in terms of danger no mana
wanna doesn't rank in in fact when I go
out into the high schools I can't tell
the kids that all drugs are harmful the
drugs are destructive I think I'm doing
a disservice I have to make distinctions
if they're going to use drugs there are
some drugs that a lot worse than others
there are some drugs that a lot more
destructive than others so in terms of
legalization you're not willing to say
that any of the drug laws should be
changed you see it more as a societal
problem of getting into the sources the
causes of what leads people I think
you're only feeding the habit you're not
really getting to the source and by the
way we're interested as radicals in
politicizing people in getting them
active in being involved in their
community I can tell you from personal
experience the
drugs is not an empowering it cripples
people drugs does not build community it
destroys community drugs is not
something that we as people who are
thinking about political or political
change should be advocating because it
really serves to do is basically
narcotized people and seduce them into
success in the way that things are as
they are do you think that we should
recriminate the use of tobacco products
illegal listen if I had my druthers if I
had my druthers people wouldn't drink
let's see I'd have to make a distinction
that are obviously people who can
integrate alcohol a couple of drinks or
so into their life and it does not have
destructive negative consequences or you
could say the same thing about taking a
couple of puffs of marijuana or maybe a
I also cocaine well I suppose you can in
fact there are people who use cocaine
that way I bet the profile a person that
I laid out to you people who come from
highly dysfunctional families who really
never get to feel good except when they
use chemicals those people are very
vulnerable I mean if you're talking
about people who in their life have
assets before back on I don't mean just
financial assets but they have
supportive family loving friends they
have a decent job they have a nice place
to live sure they may in fact I guess
technically possible they could have
drugs they can integrate it into their
lives something they might do once in a
while recreationally but if you have
people who have nothing else to look
forward in their life except drugs as a
means to feel good to feel better at
least temporarily
that's a powerless powerful seductive
idea isn't it and yet as laws now and
the way they're using these laws they
want to throw all of these people into
prison both groups the casual user
they're not doing I don't think
themselves at war I mean I've been I've
been a very observant of the policy
making drug making policy in the last
few years there has been a right-wing it
Genda basically to use the used drugs
for pretty much locking up about about a
third of the population I think if some
of these guys had their way they were
talking about for a while shooting down
planes that they suspected of carrying
carrying drugs drug smuggling they were
talking about locking up first-time
users they were talking about the death
penalty for pushers making no
distinction between most users are
oftentimes dealers if the only way to
cut down on their overhead they were
talking about throwing families of users
out of federal housing in other words
you might be a a mother raising six kids
and your teenage son uses sells drugs
and his court the whole family gets
thrown out a felon and a federal housing
that was Jack Kemp's idea well that
didn't go through the Congress you know
this we shouldn't be sort of clumsy
about the way we talk about politics in
Washington there are people in
Washington who are fighting a civil
libertarian position who are basically
trying to see drugs in a broader context
are trying to get treatment for addicts
are trying to deal with this in a more
preventive basis I think so far they've
been able to fight off this right-wing
agenda which is quite anti civil
libertarian in its in its in its import
but some of the people pushing these
obnoxious proposals are people like
George Bush and William Bennett who are
two of the highest authorities in this
country and the so-called war on drugs
so we have to be very vigilant of what
their latest program is going to be we
haven't even mentioned this drug testing
that there's been a lot of trial
balloons about testing anyone who has a
federal job at Beast when he was
Attorney General was telling employers
they should give drug tests to all their
employees anyone that doesn't pass is
fired
they should have checks in the locker
rooms and the parking lots etcetera so
there's very serious attempts to carry
out a war on drugs that will be a war on
civil liberties in this country by the
right-wing so far the Liberals have more
or less kept most of these extreme
right-wing problems also
liberals but the folks on in law there's
also concern
one shouldn't forget there's also
conservatives who have fears of a strong
Big Brother state so there's an alliance
among liberals and and and conservatives
in its traditional sense about not
wanting to see the growth of state power
as a check on this unleashed anti sub
libertarian fervor but there's also
liberals who go along with conservatives
on some of their social law programs and
if the war on drugs becomes hysterical
if there's some major murders let us say
through a drug abuse etc it's
conceivable Congress could pass an
extremely repressive drug laws so I
think this is a very dangerous and very
tense issue for this country and until
we do come with more humane and more
rational perspectives on the whole drug
problem this could easily be something
that conservative or even liberal
politicians too could manipulate in very
pretentious ways well the interesting
thing about it is is it's clear from
watching the circus for several years
now is that drugs are a political
football I mean it's a very it's a
winner of an issue as a politician to
run on afterwards overtly going to come
out and say I'm for drugs you can't be
soft on drugs it's like you couldn't be
soft on communism so so really they
really have no they are really there was
there there's no there's no cost to
being a drunk warrior but in the same
time it's been a political football I
think that the discussion the way that
the terms of the debate had been framed
have depoliticized the issue by only
talking about a war on drugs the public
discussion has been over the tactics of
the war should we go down to Colombia
should we extradite the the leader
should we destroy the crops should we
lock up users should we be executing
pushers should we be throwing people out
of federal housing should we have
mandatory testing but this emphasis on
tactic has obscured a much more
fundamental examination a much more
introspective approach that would look
at what are the underlying assumptions
of the war and basically both the
Democratic and
publican parties have been more parties
in this matter they both have been
advocating a much more stringent attack
on drugs than looking at it a much more
holistic and larger contextual
understanding they really have not been
for that and that's essentially what we
need and we're not getting that kind of
discussion from either of the major
parties